the bureau will no longer accept for
your request through email it seems like
we're creating a lot of extra burden for
the public and for reporters your FBI
remains in the forefront of both the
training and technology for criminal
investigation once upon a time all you
needed to send a Freedom of Information
Act request or Hoya to the FBI was an
email address a computer and a dream but
today on march first 2017 things are
about to change yes VI is making changes
for the way Freedom of Information
requests are submitted the bureau will
no longer accept for your request
through email requests will have to be
sent via facto standard mail or
submitted using an online portal we all
know the FBI is a little skittish when
it comes to saying or doing anything
publicly Jesus even people outside their
building in Washington or camera shy but
moving away from email seems like a
craven attempt to slow the flow of
information out of the bureau and what
was figured out a few weeks ago it hurt
the ears of foyer researchers lawyers
and reporters everywhere the FBI said
that this is to make the process more
efficient and that it won't change the
number of requests someone can submit it
seems like we're creating a lot of extra
burden for the public and for reporters
that's not a marshal he's an attorney
with the reporters Committee for freedom
of the press and he says that this move
away from email isn't helpful to
government transparency in the slightest
email is best I mean it's just the most
ubiquitous form of communication out
there right everyone is used to emails
it creates a permanent record it's got a
time stamp on it everyone knows how to
use it and it's not clear to me why the
federal government thinks that we need
to use different methods of
communication that it wants to use that
it may make it slightly easier for
agencies but that really burden the
requester just think about how powerful
FOIA is for reporters so it's incredibly
important for a journalist it's actually
the prime I would say one of the primary
ways that journalists get documents from
the government and it forms the basis of
an incredible array of stories that
means everything from vice news
revealing that Edward Snowden had
approached his bosses about national
security agency spying to the Colorado
Springs Gazette revealing that the army
was discharging injured and trauma
ridden soldiers for misconduct to the
Associated Press figuring out oh hey
we're still giving former Nazis social
security benefits
now I know what you're thinking it's not
as if reporters weren't able to do good
reporting like this before email so
what's the bad about facts or snail mail
the toner can run out right on the fax
machine right or someone might you know
pick up the phone and interrupt the fax
line I mean I have big memories of this
stuff happening when I had like dial-up
internet access right like in the 90s
and then with mail you know the others
get lost and one of the other things
that's frustrating with mail is that
most mail to go to federal agencies have
to go through a screening process
sometimes they irradiated to make sure
there aren't you know answers and
anthrax or other things in it so it can
take a long time actually for your mail
to get from you to the FOIA officer
who's going to open it up and read it
agencies are supposed to provide some
kind of response within 20 business days
and if you're for your request is in
transit for you know two weeks or three
weeks it's hard for a FOIA requester to
know exactly what's going on and that
online portal where you electronically
fill out a bunch of boxes you still have
a 3,000 character restriction on what
you can ask for which seems fine if
you're just asking for a few items but
it may not be fine if your items are
sensitive federal law enforcement
documents where you need a few
paragraphs to explain why you need them
also not all requests can be fulfilled
with a portal and it seems you're on a
need-to-know basis on what can be
fulfilled oh and just so you know trying
to inform the public about how the FBI
work has never been easy the Bureau has
multiple computerized filing systems for
documents and well good luck if you
don't know what to ask for what usually
happens in ninety-nine percent of the
cases is the FBI will search this thing
called the central reference which is a
database a system of records that the
FBI maintains it has a lot of records in
it but not all records and it's
incredibly confusing actually like this
is part of my job to know how this works
and I still find it incredibly confusing
and I think what's frustrating is that a
lot of people knitting for requests
don't know that unless you say something
different like search this record system
this record system the FBI is only
searching this one record system and
possibly in a limited way that isn't
really going to find what you're
actually looking for and it's just silly
because FOIA isn't supposed to be you
know a game of like
got you it like oh if you mention you
know this minor thing then you'll get
the records you're looking for but it's
in practice it seems like that's the
kind of system that the FBI has set up
the worst part of all of this is that
the FBI is not the only agency moving
away from email for FOIA according to
marshall 11 other government agencies
have recently stopped accepting emailed
requests I think it's great to keep the
pressure up on federal agencies and say
hey this law is for our benefit not
yours and we want to you know have ways
of submitting requests and working with
the law that make it possible for us to
do our job so I hope that more agencies
won't go the way of the eff that the FBI
has chosen to go but it certainly seems
like that's a developing trend and
that's really unfortunate
[Music]